so with the release of the latest
trailer for Dragon Ball super broadly I
see many people out there breaking the
trailer down contemplating about what
might happen at the movie isn't showing
us yet and you know me I just gotta
throw my two cents into this already
lofty pile of pennies so today I will be
discussing one by one the things I think
the movie needs in order to be the
perfect film well it's the perfect
Dragon Ball film for me but before we
start I kind of want to put a twist on
this video instead of just a list of
things that I want
I've ordered it such that the first one
yeah it's probably going to happen and
then the last one is almost definitely
not going to happen
so I've ordered it in order of
likelihood oh also spoiler alert I could
be completely wrong so let's start with
something we already have a good amount
of evidence for a sort of visual
revolution if you will in short Dragon
Ball super bro lean needs to and I think
will look fantastic
I say need because of that elephant in
the room Dragon Ball super is the
regardless of how well that series look
towards the end the popular consensus
says Dragon Ball super looks terrible it
has terrible animation even though I
would argue that's entirely wrong if you
ask anyone in the know they will go one
step further in saying that that was
largely due to two main factors number
one being the time restraints and number
two the designs toyoshima Moro produced
for the series yeah they weren't great
now what makes this new movie special
however is that it's addressing those
two main concerns right out the gate
they've hired a new character designer
in now hero shintani
who is also wearing the hat of animation
supervisor his designs have a sort of
nostalgic dragonball feel to them and
that is not a bad thing but it's also
not the only good thing to talk about
regarding the visuals with the upcoming
movie oh lordy no enter Yuya taka
[Music]
yes Yuya Takahashi is also acting as an
animation supervisor and his work is
clearly on display for the trailer to
Dragon Ball super bro Lee's been given
the time to be great it has the talent
working behind it to look great and now
that is exactly what the Dragon Ball
brand needs in order to make an
impression on the world that's watching
I guess we're talking about this now huh
I'm aware a lot of people have strong
feelings about this indisputably cannon
addition to the franchise oh god its
cannon I mean when the creator of a show
writes of saying we have to deal with it
acknowledge it and get on with our lives
you know like those relatives for
Christmas
looking at you aunty Mary as many of you
know when a trailer drops for
anticipated release you better believe
folks will comb through that thing frame
by car damn frame and one thing they
notice from the trailer was this this
too many people looked like a direct
reenactment of a significant panel in
you guessed it Akira Toriyama's 2014
Dragon Ball - which focuses on Goku's
backstory before he was sent to earth
now this isn't all bad news as I
personally don't believe this would be a
one-to-one remake of the manga however
it will be taking specific elements from
it as made evident by the latest trailer
supposedly however according to an
interview with an executive producer of
the movie he expects and I quote you'll
cry in the first 20 to 30 minutes now
whether or not that's from emotional
investment or your own personal despair
over the money you've lost on these
movie tickets is another question
entirely but at least they are going for
something different which I cannot lie I
am very excited for the beginning of
this film looks to be heavily based on
Dragon Ball - but my hope is that its
referential and loosely based at most
I'm not a huge fan of Dragon Ball - and
I think it's a little uninspired
compared to what we had originally with
Bardock the father of Goku but on the
other hand I'm happy that they are going
for an emotional resonance to Dragon
Ball for a change so if you guys want an
idea of what movies first two might be
like maybe give - or read
this one is sort of feeding off my last
statement in a sense what I want our
great character moments and when I say
that I don't mean huge climactic battles
with extraordinary set pieces
Goku turning Super Saiyan and Gohan's
battle against L are the kind of moments
people remember from Dragon Ball which
leads many folks to think that those are
the moments that makes Dragon Ball great
that is in my opinion objectively and it
arguably wrong Dragon Ball is remembered
for those moments but it's the
interactions narrative choices and
character development leading up to
those moments that make them mean what
they do in the end so I hate to break it
to you
it needs slice-of-life stuff it needs
meaningful dialogue scenes aka a good
[ __ ] story and going by the looks of
the latest trailer drop by toy it seems
to be a much more character-driven story
with emotional undertones I'm genuinely
optimistic because I really haven't seen
a Dragon Ball Phil approach a story like
this ie might be in the minority here
but ultimately this only the big moments
matter mentality is why when I was
growing up I didn't love any of the
Dragon Ball movies I stumbled across on
Cartoon Network
cooller never cared about it Lord slug
why should I care for the longest time
Brawley was a shining example of
everything I not just disliked but hated
about the franchise everything just felt
like fanservice with the amount of time
invested into the visuals I very much
hope that the script got the same
treatment ignoring the series Canon
ignoring the fight scenes and even
ignoring the big set pieces what I am
looking for above all else is a
compelling story filled with personality
and character moments and speaking of
moments how about giving Vegeta some
love
it's no secret that Vegeta has been
shafted both in the series and the
movies in relation to coming out on top
during pivotal moments which is a shame
considering he's one of if not the most
popular character on the show usually
relegated to being the butt of a joke or
battle fodder to establish how strong
the bad guy really is before Goku steps
in to give him the old one-two what I
would like to see and I'm sure I'm not
in the minority here is for Vegeta to be
given his dues
however unlike prior films where the
point would be solely founded in
flimsily held together with masking tape
Oh Dragon Ball super bro Lee looks
promising for the same Prince I say this
because an interview with the executive
producers of the film have them saying
this Vegeta is really cool in the film -
it's a change of pace from him lately
just being used for gangs and are
getting beaten up on top of that we are
all but assured that Gogeta will play a
role in the upcoming film - and you
can't have a Gogeta without Vegeta so
that at the very least means Betina
plays a pivotal role in the upcoming
Japanese flick in some capacity so you
better not screw me on this toey not
like last time as mentioned towards the
beginning of this video
brouilly was not only a character I
disliked he was a character I
specifically hated for a number of
reasons reason number one he lacked any
real motive in any of his films
Goku crying isn't a motive worth killing
over
reason number two outside of his design
he offers nothing new to the story of
Dragon Ball in fact if the old brouilly
was witness to the main story of the
show he would actively make it worse
simply by being there finally reason
number three brouilly embodied precisely
why hazed about Dragon Ball and its
perception among other anime fans as
well as the casual viewer Dragon Ball is
not about kick man versus punch man
explosion happens the end no of course
not it's about its characters and how
compelling we find them to be this is
sort of a tangent on the topic but it's
for that very reason Super Saiyan blue
fell flat for a lot of people while it
was unveiled in resurrection F it meant
nothing go on turning Super Saiyan 2
meant something to us because throughout
the entire series we followed his story
and watched
grow that's the [ __ ] that matters and
while I am not that hopeful for Broly I
do have some hope reason being when the
first trailer was released a number of
months back akira toriyama released a
statement regarding his involvement and
the character of rolling this is what it
said so about Broly i hear these days
he's still very popular not only in
Japan but overseas based on that my
editor suggested we had Broly appear in
the next film I went ahead and watched
the movies from back then and felt this
could be quite interesting once I
rearranged a few things I got right to
work trying my hand at a story that
incorporates him into the Dragon Ball
super series with that Toriyama has
given me enough indication here that he
will change the character someone to at
least give me hope for the film's
titular saying only time will tell
different doesn't always mean better and
definitely does not mean good but I
welcome any change from what it used to
be many of you guys watching this might
know that I love love love Frieza I
hated the resurrection F story arc in a
sense but Frieza has always been a
character I found endlessly entertaining
his involvement with the tournament of
power was the sole reason I was invested
in that story at any capacity and so it
will come as no surprise I'm sure to you
that I want this movie to really utilize
freeze it to the best of its ability I
mean really it seems like he's the
catalyst for the movie the movie seems
to be taking a particular focus on three
characters and the fact they were born
around the same time those three
characters being Goku Vegeta and Broly
and this is where I hope the one thread
tying these three together is Frieza
it's thanks to freezes threat to the
planet Vegeta Bardock ng descent Goku
off to earth it's thanks to that same
event Vegeta lost his planet and became
enslaved and oh Jesus Christ on an
inflatable bike do I hope brawly's
motivation is something substantial this
time we know that he was exiled but
that's it
why was he exiled as still unknown the
reason behind his exhalation hey the
reason why he was exiled is still
unknown and I hope it's good and if it
involves Frieza in some capacity I think
that will make the battle these two
ultimately have in the movie all the
more compelling which is what I want
more than the fighting itself and come
on use piccolo oh and show Android 17 on
a boat that'll be dope
this one I think is what I am
potentially most interested in put quite
simply I want this movie to mean
something and have lasting consequences
when battle of gods was released in 2013
you know before you could inexplicably
watch the entire thing on YouTube it
turned the entire Dragon Ball universe
on its head to achieve this battle of
gods took the time to establish two new
characters the god of destruction beerus
and his quirky attendant Wiese the
addition of these characters opened up a
multiverse of opportunities for both the
film and any subsequent stories they
might tell thereafter essentially what I
want from Dragon Ball super Broly is a
strong introduction to new characters
and to keep those characters around
don't just pull an attack on titan by
introducing us to these characters for
the lone reason of killing them off
later on it's being here that I'm still
not overly my squad on top of that I'd
love to see this film end on a
cliffhanger something that teases the
audience watching leaving us wanting
more a continuation of the series
perhaps whatever the case I want the
story to feel big to feel important I've
heard many people criticize resurrection
F for being a bad follow-up to battle of
gods jus in some respects to the scale
of that movie battle of gods opened up
this enormous world for us to explore
and resurrection F did nothing with that
now I'm not saying I want the Brawley
movie to blow battle of gods right out
of the water when it comes to scale but
I at the very least wanted to feel big
and to feel like it's part of a bigger
story at the end of the day I'm gonna go
see this movie regardless if they have a
bloody worldwide release I'm still
waiting on hearing if it's in Ireland
yet there's more to the world than just
America why can't I get a straight
answer is it worldwide or not geez
anyway the point is if we're going off
the promo material as one of the
trailers for the film that's being
released if nothing else it will be
absolutely gorgeous to watch and heck
the best-case scenario is that toy made
good and all the promises made and it
turned out to be the best film to date
for the franchise
it certainly has all the necessary
components to be such but that's all for
now leave me your thoughts in the
comment section down below I'd love to
hear what you think are you gonna go see
the movie what do you think it's gonna
be like until next time guys I have been
toying up mark thank you so much for
watching
you